once you pass these gates you're
entering the town of madinabai
no alcohol and smoking is not permitted
on its streets
considered to be a holy place by those
who visit here
this remote town 200 kilometers from
senegal's capital dakar is a stronghold
of tejani sufis
they have their roots in algeria and
morocco and gained popularity during the
anti-colonial struggle against the
french
madina bay is now a place of spiritual
pilgrimage for sufis across africa
and it's also attracted black american
students to come and study at its school
us african americans
as a place or a safe haven for us to
practice our religion
and learn our religion um also it's also
an invitation back home giving us a
piece of ourselves that we that was lost
or taken away from us
during slavery many of those enslaved
came from west africa for some there's a
sense this has been a journey of return
when the plane landed as soon as my feet
hit the ground i began to cry
this is the first time that i have ever
been home
what made you cry the fact that i was
home after 500 year journey
the town and the sufi order are
significant for senegal
since independence every president
that's been elected has visited this
small town every year hundreds of
thousands of pilgrims flock here it's
the beating heart of the spirituality in
senegal
is responsible for western students he
doesn't shy away from how influential
the movement is and says senegal's
president maki saleh is well aware of
their importance
we are citizens like other citizens
but we have
this medina we have
this followers
that make isla he used to live here in
siam so he knows his medina
he know what's going on in medina
he know that medina is a part very
important part in senegal
but for those who move here from the
united states it's a spiritual quest
with its own challenges
joy farzan is from atlanta and she came
here with her children
you know the language barrier and they
were worried about making friends
missing some of the foods from home
getting used to the food here
but now they love it they love the
freedom there's no doubt the sufis are a
social and political force here where
religion also plays a central role in
people's lives
and although in other countries
religious influence may be considered a
negative aspect
here it's seen as a positive even
essential
[Music]
[Applause]
assad al-jazeera medina by senegal